like we were talking about before when
you meet someone who can give you a
lesson and and express something in a
way that makes you reconsider your own
ideas you hold sacred I mean I'll give
you an example when I when I met my wife
30 years ago I wasn't pro death penalty
but I was I would say I was having
neutral to the death penalty I would be
like you know Ted Bundy the state can
put him to death and I had all the kind
of conventional reasons or I didn't
really care he's a vile person he killed
all these people he tortured them if the
families will get any relief whatever
that's fine I had some concerns because
I was a statistician about conviction of
the innocent and I support the Innocence
Project and I am very concerned with
police brutality I have for years been
advocating there the racializing of
police brutality is vile and and
abhorrent and must be firmly resisted I
think that I think the the the
prosecutorial misconduct away people are
prosecutors lie and put people in prison
you know there have been many many cases
people on death row who are innocent
that should offend our conscience so
even back then I had some concerns about
the death penalty because I because I I
recognized that you know we can't be
perfect we're gonna convict some
innocent people and also let some guilty
people go free that's not as bad as
killing the putting to death the
innocent but they're both bad so I had
that concern about the death penalty but
otherwise I was like it's okay my
opinions have totally changed I'm
completely opposed to the death penalty
now for many reasons not just the
statistical reason but also I think it's
immoral I don't think the state should
put it out I think we can rip deprive
you of Liberty I think we can make sure
you're not a threat to society we can
lock you up for the rest of your life
but I think we the state should not be
taking people's lives in that way
there's something extraordinarily
strange about locking someone up it's
very strange
well we we have a car serial state I
mean you know we lock up a higher we
have is we are fraction of people
incarcerated I think is the same as
Stalinist Russia and we have very long
prison sentences which are nuts you
don't need them for deterrence actually
for nonviolent drug specially for not
all nonviolent offenses should have much
we should have more we should have
higher certainty of punishment a higher
fraction of people who have actually
commit a crime should be punished but I
think we should we could cut in half or
less the the duration of the census I
think you'll be able to deter criminals
from doing things with a three-month
sentence if they are very confident that
they will be convicted if they're caught
whereas now we have a system where most
are not convicted like this jessi
Smollett thing which is just ridiculous
in the news yes and and which therefore
the Saudi and only a tiny fraction are
convicted and but they're given huge
long sentences it's like they're paying
the cents for everyone that didn't yes
it does make any sense and it's
expensive it ties up our prison system I
should I'm gonna go to tell you another
story that's wrong so as a situation a
few years ago when there's a very famous
director and writer by the name of David
Simon who I consider a friend he did the
wire he was a showrunner for a bunch of
other very famous wonderful TV programs
he started his career actually as a
reporter in in Baltimore he was a beat
reporter and then went on to become a
writer did the wire and so forth and he
told the story actually at Yale to
students about how he had just come back
from a summit President Obama was still
president where he was trying to help
the students to see that you could find
common ground with your political
opponents and that you need to listen to
them and talk to them in order to define
that ground if and so he told the
following story he said I just came back
from Camp David where there was a
meeting about how to reduce
incarceration in our society and he said
the Koch brothers were there and the
students all hissed and Newt Gingrich
was there and the students all hissed
and a bunch of liberal people were there
and the students were really happy about
that
and then they said well why did you go
how could you associate yourself with
those evil people and he said look he
said the the conservatives want to
reduce incarceration because it's
expensive the liberals want to reduce
incarceration because it's unjust and
the libertarians want to reduce
incarceration because the state
shouldn't be depriving people of Liberty
and I can find common ground with these
people and reduce incarceration why
would
not talk to them and the students didn't
seem to understand that they were like
they couldn't get it that's why they
shouldn't be able to vote yeah 30 25
something I mean and so I don't know how
we got onto this you know like talking
to you is so much fun because it's like
we're all over the place but um how did
I get it come up with this example we
were talking about talking to political
enemies was it or something else yes
we're talking about people telling you
that you shouldn't associate yes people
that have varying opinions are sir a
ssin and imprison senses and so forth so
we have a horrible problem in our
society with with incarceration a larger
fraction of our populace is incarcerated
we deprive after you paid your debt to
society we often have these these we
deprive you of your right to vote which
i think is wrong you paid your debt to
society you should be able to reenter
society that applies is yes exactly yes
exactly you were in prison for 10 years
that's enough you know now you we want
you to feel part of society we want to
welcome you back if we have that vision
of justice how about the registered sex
offender that's a serious problem
especially for crimes
you know these crazy cases which offend
my conscience I know a guy who got
charged as a registered sex offender
because he urinated outside
yeah that's not caught in the South
urinating outside that's not so that's
just prosecutorial abuse or you know you
have these Romeo and Juliet laws which
are not in every state now thank God
they alas they are not in every state
you know you have a 16 year old boy and
a 14 year old girl there have to be
exceptions for that kind of sexual
practice you know they're exchanging
sexually explicit images they should not
be considered sex offenders for the rest
of their lives that's nuts so um so yes
so all of those things so the problem is
not like we have a huge fraction of
people in prison we have extremely long
prison sentences compared to any many
European countries for the same crime
and it's costly it's unjust it's
ineffective I think I think we should
change the policies on this and maybe we
will there's also the idea of reforming
them it's it's they're not using all the
tools within their disposal they're not
real
yeah good attempt at it and I just don't
think it does anything other than make
their life hell for a short period of
time which we're hoping we hope deters
them from doing future crime well
they're different there's the justice
there's deterrence their safety right
like so violent criminals that we put in
jail we need to do that I mean - not
interested in being killed by somebody
who you know could killed someone else
she should be in jail for a while
20 years sometime on a time murder yeah
for murder I think they'd think 20 years
is enough well European so European
standards are about 20 years actually
and there are different things like if
you want to deprive them if your if your
vision is they're being punished for the
killing of a life therefore they've
surrendered their life it's sort of eye
for an eye kind of justice you would
they would be the rest of their lives
since you yes and you know I we can
debate whether that's reasonable or not
if you if you want to provide a public
safety reason people often age out of
their violence so a lot of men typically
these were talking mostly about men who
do these things you know by the time
they're in their 40s or 50s they're much
less violent testosterone declines they
get older and wiser they're not
interested in in criminal and that kind
of criminal behavior many of them are
not so that does that suggest you don't
need life sentences for murder and I
think it also depends and we have four
gradations of murder you know we have
like the impulsive stuff that intent
matters the plan fulness matters that
depravity matters all of these things
are our factors and I don't think we
should have a one-size-fits-all
incarceration for murder yes that's my
opinion what do you think I think it
depends entirely on the circumstance if
two men are engaged in some sort of a
dispute and one winds up killing the
other one that's a big difference
between that and someone breaking in
your house and killing your daughter yes
correct and I also think even in that
like I I really am opposed to these
Stand Your Ground laws I think those are
if you have the opportunity to avoid
conflict and to avoid you are not you it
I would prefer as a state to require
that you walk away even if it makes you
feel embarrassed then give you the right
to kill someone for offending you and
those those videos of the of the guys in
that
the guy on his knees in the in the
parking lot in that I forgot what state
it was like not long ago or two ago they
got into an altercation in the parking
lot look if I have words with someone in
a partnership Shawn the guy on his knee
yes there was no threat to him and he
was he was not prosecuted on the stand
your ground argument which is nuts
why was the guy on his knees he was I
forgot he said don't shoot me or
something Jesus so it was it was crazy
didn't get prosecuted I don't think so
we can look up the facts there were
several cases there were several cases
like this but you know like I remember
when I was doing Shotokan Karate my
sensei Kazumi Tabata this was years ago
the 30 years ago now and he told us the
following story he said there was a
sensei in this village in Japan and the
students were coming to the dojo and
there was the the the best student the
you know and then all the other students
and they were walking through the
village and they passed they approached
a horse that was on the street from the
rear and it startled the horse and as
the horse reared up and kicked its leg
the the the best student instantly did a
kind of avoidance kind of twisted his
body and avoided the kick in the and the
and the the horse's leg went right in
front of him and all the other students
were amazed at his ability and they get
to the dojo and they tell the sensei
this is my sensei telling me this story
telling all of us this story and they
those students get to this dojo and they
tell the the sensei the story marveling
at the ability of this master student to
deftly avoid the strike and the sensei
is very angry and they don't understand
why why is he so angry he said if he
were a really good student of mine he
would have walked on the other side of
the street he would have avoided a horse
altogether so the real wisdom is to
avoid avoidance of conflict in the first
place there's no reason to seek out
conflict yeah and so on these
stand-your-ground laws you know if the
choices either you just avoid the
conflict you know someone someone swore
at you or called you an asshole or was
unreasonable jerk that doesn't give you
the right to kill them right so anyway I
don't know how we got on to this as well
the penalty for price or murder exactly
it
actly so different gradations yeah yeah
I just don't know how much of a
deterrent it is locking people up I just
I'm not sure I'm not really sure if that
actually stops people from doing things
I think it stops some people I think
they're been academic research on this I
just don't think there's any real
rehabilitation other than personal
choice I mean I think that the the real
rehabilitation comes from someone making
a personal choice to never be that
person that way yes for most of them
you're you you're being locked up with a
bunch of hardened criminals you you
that's you're you're completing but
you're not suggesting we have a society
in which when you commit violent acts we
do nothing no I'm not no no no I'm
suggesting you're struggling with this
is what you're saying yeah the yeah the
concept of nuances yes this is this is
applied here better than anywhere else I
think I got the impression looking at
your face a moment ago when I told my
sort of sweet sense a Japanese karate
story that you didn't agree necessarily
no that's a very wise way oh yeah yeah
don't don't be near a fucking horse at
once yeah
very smart yeah get out of there I'm a
big believer in avoiding conflict yeah
I'm the first guy not intellectual Cosmo
yeah exact words and violence are
different right actually extremely
different yeah I mean intellectual
conflict that is actually important and
you learn from it yes very rarely do you
learn too much right you will learn
don't do that again that's how you learn
from physical conflict